thanks for the invitation to the
organizers and thanks everyone for
coming so today I'm gonna be talking to
you about some recent and in-progress
joint work with my friend Julian Salazar
bouder who's currently at Cambridge and
this might be of a moderately different
flavour this will tell you how to
transform information about the roots of
probably generating functions into
central limit theorems with very little
effort
so hopefully this might be something
where you can just hit some of your
existing facts with these types of
theorems and you'll recover some
theorems so first what is a probability
generating function so if you're given a
discrete random variable let's assume
that it's bounded you can define its
probability generating function by just
summing up the probability x equals K
times e to the K so you'll notice a
couple of quick properties about this
I assume that X is bounded so this guy
is genuinely a polynomial not like some
long power series the coefficients are
non-negative and in fact when I plug in
1 we get 1 and if you're here there's
maybe a chance that you really don't
care about random variables but you do
care of polynomials so this could be
your definition of a probability
generating function so really this last
condition is quite easy to make happen
you have to divide by whatever scales in
it 1 to make that occur the real killer
fact here is non-negative coefficients
so let's talk about a couple of
properties if you have independent
random variables and you add them then
the generating functions just multiply
and by evaluating Z to e to the I theta
we can relate the generating functions
to the characteristic function or the
Fourier transform characteristic
function is a probabilistic all the
Fourier transform I'll probably just
call it the Fourier transform for the
most part here but I'll use them
interchangeably I'm a particular this
means that this polynomial uniquely
determines the distribution of X so a
quick review of some probability theory
so the characteristic function of a
normal is just e to a polynomial of
degree 2 so this first term is basically
the mean and the second one is the
variance over 2 you can define the
cumulants of a random variable by just
to expanding the log of this moment
generating function here and you'll
notice that having the third fourth
fifth and so on cumulants being
identically zero means that you are in
normal random variable these are of
course different than the free cumulants
which we've seen earlier today these are
like the classical cumulants we of
course also have the continuity theorem
which says that if you have a sequence
of these random variables whose Fourier
transforms converge let's say to e to
the negative theta squared over 2 then
you get converges a distribution to a
standard normal so let's start with a
big fuzzy question what is relationship
between these roots and the distribution
of X so let's start with a totally
extreme case that's probably familiar to
most of you which is what happens if we
assume that all of our roots are
genuinely real so since the coefficients
are non-negative all of these roots must
be non positive so we write them as a
negative R 1 through negative R N and we
could of course factor this guy and
you'll notice that we rescale such that
each of these linear factors is 1 at 1
and then we recognize that this is the
generating function of a zero one random
variable with a certain probability of
being one so we can decompose our
regional random variable the sum of
independent random variables that are 0
1 and then if we hit this with you know
the old-fashioned central limit theorem
like let's say the Lindenberg central
limit theorem when the variance of X is
large you end up with getting a random
variable that's close to normal when I
recenter it rescale so let's talk here
about a an example this that this isn't
just like some random toy case as I'm
sure most of you know if you give me
just a graph G and you let M K denote
the number of matchings with K edges we
can look at the generating function for
these and you end up with something real
rooted of course here I'm talking about
like partial matchings I don't need to
have every vertex being hit
this is a theorem with helman leave
which has come up a couple of times so
far here now this means that if we
choose a matching uniformly at random
then provided the variance is quite
large the number of edges in this
matching is going to be close to a
normal when a recenter and we scale so
well let's take it up a tiny bit and
talk about it slightly more delicate
case so let's say we have a sequence of
these discrete random variables and
suppose that there's some Delta such
that all the roots of all of my
generating functions are no more than
Delta within one so I know less than
Delta with a month they avoid a disk of
radius Delta around 1 let's assume also
that our variance is bounded below by
the degree of this polynomial to the 2/3
they end up with the central limit
theorem so you'll notice here that we're
not adding up these random variables
it's the underlying random variables
themselves that converge to normality
this is this theorem by Leibowitz piddle
ghrelin spear from 2016 i think it was
on archived and maybe 2014 they are
primarily interested in like spin state
models like certain facts about the
Ising model and also certain graph
counting questions which will come back
later on so in words this says that
having no roots near 1 together with
this sort of mysterious variance
condition implies asymptotic normality
so why is this possibly true
you can still factor a polynomial over C
and now you'll notice these are the
linear factors where when I plug in 1 I
get 1 obviously these are not
probability generating functions like
there have complex coefficients but we
can still sort of pretend that they are
and the factor corresponding to a root
lambda would correspond to some sort of
random variable where the probabilities
are defined by the coefficients of this
polynomial by probabilities they're
complex numbers but they still add up to
1 and now this mass is complex valued
and the modulus of the mass for a linear
factor is going to blow up as lambda
approaches 1
so in some sort of vague sketchy way the
idea is that if you have no roots near
one York involving a lot of measures
none of which is much larger than the
other so believably you should get a
central limit theorem of some kind so
that's all very hand wavy you can make
that much more precise so we can factor
our polynomial and now if lambdas
uniformly bounded away from one we can
Taylor expand the log characteristic
function of like one of these individual
guys and this Big O term is going to be
uniform provided lambdas uniformly
bounded away and now when I add up all
of those I get log of the characteristic
function for my original guy and now I
have a mean and I have my variance over
two and I still have this error term
where now since I've added up m n of
these factors I get a term of MN there
and now when we renormalize this term is
going to go to zero
because I've assumed that MN divided by
variance to three halves is going to go
to zero and that tells you that you get
a central limit theorem okay an
interesting fact about this which
doesn't explicitly appear in the
Leibowitz fiddle and at all paper is
that this works for all polynomials and
nowhere did we make use of non-negative
coefficients so if we all of a sudden
define the mean of a polynomial to be
what it would be if we had a generating
function sorry if this were probably the
generating function and the variance the
same way we can say that a sequence of
polynomials satisfies the central limit
theorem if what would be the
characteristic function converges to the
characteristic function of a standard
normal
so of course I'm not making any
statements about like what the
coefficients are going to look like you
don't get to like use like the inversion
theorem for Fourier transforms when
you're no longer dealing with measures
you have signed measures but they in
fact prove that you have a sequence of
polynomials with roots a uniformly
avoiding one the complex plane and the
degree is killed by variance to
three-halves then you get a central
limit theorem in this sense
so this raises a question of what is up
with this variance condition right what
happens if we do make use of this non
negative coefficient stuff so and about
2016 Robyn P mantel conjectured that as
long as you avoid one and your variance
goes to infinity you should get a
central limit theorem it's worth
mentioning that variance going to
infinity is the absolute minimal
possible condition you could have for
this because we have discrete guys or
converging to something continuous you
have to be like a normalizing out by
something going to infinity
this was a touch optimistic
unfortunately we're gonna get to see
just how it like barely misses and
Julian and I came up with a sequence of
random variables that avoid one whose
variance is on the order of log but you
have no central limit theorem but Robin
was correct that there is a significant
amount of room to improve but we have to
think much more deeply about what it
means to have non-negative coefficients
and I'm gonna talk about that a little
more at length so we show if you have a
sequence of these Union for me avoid one
and now you just need that the variance
is bigger than the degree to some fixed
epsilon for any epsilon you give me
you get essential limit theorem so to
sort of recap this having no roots near
one implies normality or asymptotic
normality provided variance isn't sub
polynomial in the degree so the example
that we have avoids one and has variance
in the order of log and this is a sub
polynomial result so they're very close
to each other we have some ideas about
what the correct answer should be but
nothing super concrete okay so let's
philosophize a little bit so what does
it mean to have positive coefficients so
if I tell you Pauling that has positive
coefficients what information do we gain
so a basic fact is that none of its
roots are positive is good if you plug
in a positive number you're not going to
get zero but obviously much more occurs
so
here's the theorem that kind of
encapsulates that just let's say that
you give me a polynomial and I'm telling
you that the constant term in the top
term are positive just so we don't have
to rescale it or anything like this then
the following are equivalent having all
sufficiently high powers having positive
coefficients is equivalent to the linear
in the trace term being positive and
having this condition known as strong
positivity which says that your
polynomial is dominated by its value on
the real axis if I just like dragged
along the circle and hit the real axis
so why are we thinking about taking
powers of this polynomial well we're
really concerned with roots of
polynomials and taking powers preserves
the roots and in fact does a little more
than preserve roots and even preserves
the empirical measure of the roots which
is when you just put a point mass down
at each place a complex plane where you
have a root so this is really the best
we can hope for if we want positive
coefficients so we're thinking about
what it means for all high powers to
have positive coefficients so you can
sort of similarly ask what happens if
you want non-negative coefficients and
there is a conjecture byberg viol
Eremenko and so called about 2013 so
they assumed that the linear in the
trace term was zero and they said okay
let's suppose your bottom three and top
three coefficients are positive and you
have the strong positivity Cove
condition
then all sufficiently high powers have
non-negative coefficients so we should
this was true when we in fact got the if
and only if for having non-negative
coefficients and the point I brought
this up is it just so I can state
another result it's so that way this
condition of being strongly positive is
basically equivalent to Paris having
non-negative coefficients up to some
sort of goofy combinatorial cat
condition there's also a result by a
break violent Eremenko sort of saying
that the limits of polynomials with
non-negative coefficients in some sense
comes down to this condition if you look
at the empirical measure of these roots
so you just put a point mass down at
each a root you ask what measures can be
the weak limit of these it basically
comes down to just
this condition it's okay
how does this come into play for our
case so let's return back to random
variables so in the case of P being a
probability generating function this
strong positivity condition is the same
as a triangle inequality happening we're
just saying that the expected value of e
to some complex number times X is less
than or equal to the modulus sorry
expected value of the modulus there so
this is going to imply a statement from
probability and some people might say
harmonic analysis which is that if you
have a random variable and it's Fourier
transform is e to a polynomial then the
polynomials of degree at most two this
is a theorem of marching habits I don't
know if it's possible for a theorem to
be classic and obscure but this is I
don't know this is a fantastic theorem
and what I like first read it I was
offended no one told me about it before
it's pretty crazy so having the third
and higher cumulant all being zero just
by like the definition of ki melons
tells you you're in normal but in fact
if I tell you the tenth and higher all
zero then this tells you you're still in
normal so
right the underlying facts that make
this all work is this triangle
inequality so the proof is a complex
analysis type proof I'm not gonna really
have time to get into it what's sort of
the fact that makes it work and that
doesn't work for signed measures is that
the triangle inequality fails for signed
measures but it's true for probability
measures
so we use this to prove what's sort of
like a compactness result right and we
say okay let's say you have a sequence
of random variables and we're looking at
the cumulants sequence and now these key
moments each depend on n now if I tell
you eventually that each of these
cumulants converges and goes to infinity
to zero in some uniform sense that I
won't get into which is why this is a
rough lemma and you have some small
chemo that doesn't die then you get
convergence to a normal random variable
so I didn't want to write this out in
like the full statement and like full
rigor that it appears in our preprint
but this is sort of what the idea is is
that if you can show eventually all the
higher cumulants converges n goes to
infinity to 0 and you have enough
control over how fast that happens you
can in fact get a central limit theorem
out of it
so the idea is that if some lower
cumulant you know something like a k3
through k9 or whatever doesn't converge
to 0 then I can rescale in a way so
should I'll trap that guy I'll end up
with the limit that's e to a polynomial
of degree strictly bigger than 2 but
that's an impossibility by marching
Cabot's so that's perhaps see an example
to graph counting so our main theorem
says as long as you avoid one uniformly
they indeed you have that the variance
is bigger than the degree to some
epsilon then you get essentially theorem
so here's an example of ours from
combinatorics just let's say you just
have a sequence of graphs you're gonna
choose a sub graph of max degree at most
for uniformly at random as long as the
max degree of G doesn't grow too fast
with respect to the number of edges you
get a central limit theorem so a version
of this was proved by Leibowitz PLM
spear but they required the assumption
that the max degree was bounded so we
get this extra room from upgrading this
epsilon from one third to just any
epsilon and also we have control over
allowing roots to approach one at a
specific rate
so let's perhaps give a bird's eye view
of that the idea of this is to use
subsequent iterative sorry Isana real
contractions so if I give you let's say
a two variable multi affine polynomial
it has no zeros in some rectangle then
the polynomial where I just squashed
these two down to a single Z has no
roots in some set in control so I
imagine lots of folks here are much more
familiar with this process than I am but
this gives us sort of a recipe for
controlling roots of course recipe
should maybe be in quotes because like
everything has to conspire to go well or
if for this to work you create a large
multi fine polynomial those we're easy
to understand you subsequently just
squash down
like one variable at a time using asana
l contractions each time you keep track
of these routes at the end you get a
univariate polynomial whose a routes you
can control and a really sharp sense oh
yeah you're just mapping this polynomial
to that polynomial oh you mean in my
case in the graph counting oh no it's
just a two so you just do this in each
variable mapping two of them down to one
and you can then squash down to this so
yeah if you have three variables you
view it as like multi finding two with
coefficients also depending on the third
you just keep going yeah there's also to
make this all work but sort of doesn't
fit as nicely in this half live recipe
is like an application of grace Walsh a
go also happens you make it all
symmetric so you get everything linear
and then squash them down here any other
questions on this
okay so
we can generalize this a little bit to
higher dimensions as you guys know
there's a higher dimensional
generalization that will redo this known
as stability or real stability which is
when the polynomial is non vanishing on
the strict upper half plane there's also
an interesting experience for me because
usually I talk to probabilists who have
never heard this term and now it's like
the exact opposite you guys all know
more about this and I do but that's okay
so we can define a generating function
of a multivariate random variable really
similarly where we just sum over the
probabilities that it's equal to some
vector times z1 through ZD to that
vector and examples of such random
variables include like occupancies of
determinantal processes and we saw this
also occur in the previous talk
sort of
I'm sure you guys actually in fact have
more examples than I do okay
multivariate random variables with
stable generating function satisfy a
central limit theorem under similar
variance conditions to the central limit
theorem of Leibowitz Patronus Peter and
Ghosh look at in P mantle in 2016 proved
that if you have a sequence of random
variables with stable generating
function and you have let's say the
maximum term in your covariance matrix
can rescale your matrix to some nonzero
limit and this variance is sufficiently
large you get a central limit theorem I
think there's a question in the last
talk about whether or not there were
tearing off bounds for stable generating
functions I don't have one but we do
have a central method for them which is
in some ways similar yeah okay so how
does the proof work
the proof is look very nice and gentle
as is typical for multivariate central
limit theorems you almost always just
reduce this to the univariate case so a
version of Kramer Wald says that in
order to prove that this rescaled guy
converges in distribution to some normal
we should have to show that all linear
combinations scale to the correct linear
combination of the target distribution
so in fact Kramer walled-in it's like a
generality for like all distributions
says you have to check all projections
but for a normal you can in fact check
when you project just along vectors of
positive integers this is very lucky for
us if I start with a stable generating
function and then I take a look at such
a linear combination of it's a if I take
a look at such a projection then the
generating function of this projection
is just plugging in Z to some power for
each of them and now all I'm doing is
you're taking the upper half plane and
you're squashing it down into some
sector of the real axis more or less so
stability is going to apply that Q has
no roots in some sector and therefore Q
has no roots near one then you just have
to hit this with the central limit
theorem of Leibowitz Patil and spear and
you're done so luckily for us we
automatically get an improvement well
now you just need this variance term to
be bigger than n to the epsilon for some
Epsilon
yeah so proof of course is the same
exact thing you squashed it all down a
little faster than I intended
that's okay candidates for examples of
this would be really fantastic we
haven't thought too deeply but non
trivial examples but if you guys have
any examples of such things oh just a
random variables with stable generating
functions that aren't like the handful
that we always hear about get some kind
of maybe a synthetic version of
underwater small boat yes I do good
essence like bombs sacred what panic
summation so you can do that nice
control how your participate I normal no
we don't so we have nothing no no none
of this is at all effective yeah
unfortunately
you with that yeah so we would love to
make this more effective and be able to
look at things like that part of the
problem with this marching kbits theorem
is that it is like complex analytic in
nature and thereby a little harder than
usual to effective eyes it's something
that we are sort of working on but we
use analyticity of like yeah certain
functions at various points which means
that like it's tough to make things
approximate but that is something we're
trying to do but also to give a better
answer to question we have not looked at
that at all
any other questions and also if you
think of an example you can just tell me
anytime this week or just in general I'm
always happy to hear more facts about
this ok
so avoiding a neighborhood of 1 together
with some mild variance condition gives
you asymptotic morality
well what about criteria that doesn't
have any variance condition other than
of course variance going to infinity
it's an easy example as we saw was when
all the roots are real right you could
just hit it with just Lindenberg central
limit theorem and in fact you do get an
effective version like you do get a very
esteemed type result there oh and it's
also worth mentioning while that's
coming up Leibowitz Patil Rowland
speared do get a berry sceen type result
they do in fact have an effective
version of that which is quite nice
there's another paper by huang and
sakharova's which deals with the case
when all routes have modulus 1 so they
lie exactly in the unit circle and this
is equivalent to basically being
symmetric as an X is distributed the
same as n minus X and we also need the
probability of 0 to be positive they
prove a whole bunch of stuff but the
most relevant at least to this situation
is their central limit theorem they say
that if your roots are all in the unit
circle then you get a central limit
theorem if and only if the fourth
cumulant converges to 0 which the same
as saying that the fourth central moment
converges to 3 their paper is really
interesting fantastic but in some ways
this is the least interesting aspect of
it they classify in some sense all
possible limits of variables that have
roots in the unit circle the proof here
doesn't make use of non-negative
coefficients in fact what it does is it
directly manipulates sorry manipulates
the moment generating function and
bounds higher cumulants in terms of
certain sums of the roots and then
compares that to what happens the fourth
cumulant and etc etc again I think the
heavy lifting in their paper
is first of all they're insane listed
examples which is really fantastic and
also that they classify all possible
limits
we have a another central limit theorem
where if you give me a sequence of
random variables and suppose all the
roots go to infinity as if at a
sufficiently fast rate then provided the
variance goes to infinity you get a
central limit theorem so the this also
works when all roots go to zero
sufficiently quickly you just have to
replace X n by n minus xn and it just
flips everything from outside the unit
circle to inside the unit circle and the
proof of this is you just express
accumulates explicitly in terms of the
roots and show that some low enough
cumulant has to be large which is the
hard part here and then you hate it with
our version of this margin kbits theorem
so if you think about this in terms of
this factoring over the complex number
is from a while back right this is
really close to a Lindbergh central
limit theorem because it's telling you
that each individual point mass is very
small that's what it means for this
route to go out to infinity I have one
more slightly strange central limit
theorem so let's say you define this
region and if you can't forget what that
looks like it looks like that if you
avoid that region you get a central
limit theorem so I'll go back to the
region so we can talk about that but in
fact we don't actually need all of the
roots to avoid us for this to happen we
just need a little lo of the variance to
three-halves to avoid it and all of the
roots to avoid a neighborhood of one and
then you get a central my theorem and
this in fact generalizes the central
limit theorem of Leibowitz pol and spear
let's take a look back at this yeah
there's a while when every time I gave
this talk I kept asking if anyone had
seen this anywhere else in math and I'm
still looking for candidates could have
not but I think it's just some algebraic
curve that is very specific to
polynomials and variance okay
so I won I think a little fast but that
is all I have for you today and thank
you very much
[Applause]
she's anything but what properties of
that curve yeah so yeah let's kind of go
back to the situation where we're
factoring things so if i factor and we
have real coefficients so I can always
pair them up by conjugate or anything
unless of course they're real I look at
this dude let's call it let's say P
lambda of Z I can associate a variance
to this polynomial by pretending that
this is a generating function of a
random variable and the variance of this
guy is negative if and only if lambdas
in that set so sort of what it's telling
you here is that the obstacles to being
close to normal or when you have roots
that contribute of negatively to your
variance
and not by mistake because you make the
foolproof other Marvel non-vanishing on
the line one site so alive do you have
that one yeah positivity of coefficients
and trigonometric identities and so the
zero free region meseta is asymptotic oh
yeah okay yeah laughing take a close
look at that
well I showed this to someone and they
like immediately said folium of
descartes which is like another
algebraic a look at yeah so it's not
signed measures its probability measures
it isn't a result I remember offhand but
the reference is huang and sakharova's
they talk about what the
moment-generating functions can look
like complete is perhaps a strong term
but they have some sort of
characterization that is in some sense
complete and not totally explicit
function of a curve in the curve case in
the variables all zeroes on the circle
that we
and people have studied in the genus so
in the number of roots gets large what
are the possible weak limits and nobody
knows they some constraints
classifications yeah so it's not on the
weak limits of the measures on the unit
circle it's on the underlying random
variable associated to those polynomials
where they must emit we must be zero
smoking
so is it necessary to assume that your
uniformly bounded away from one two
routes or could it be that they just go
slowly yeah so if we have that the
variance is bigger than n to the epsilon
then we just need Delta to be bigger
than okay this is definitely a don't
quote me on that situation but yeah you
just need to be bigger than that yes so
they can't allow it to go to zero just
not faster than a certain rate oh and
here my double bigger arrow means little
Omega so grace you going to zero
[Applause]
2:30 pregnant